buzzfeed
on the count of three you always
listen to what your mother says and
never question
i'm so excited about this video right
now i'm so excited excited
excited excited today i'm going to be
learning
everything about hypnosis i'm not just
going to be learning it i'm going to do
it basically i'm going to be a god i'm
going to control people i'm going to
have so much power all these people who
never listen to me who never care what i
have to say guess what today you're
gonna do whatever i say
so this is easy hypnosis is basically
just people being controlled by their
subconscious mind i don't know if you
guys get it but i get it so i'm gonna go
test it out on some people
swish can i try and hypnotize you um i
guess
all right we're gonna do this ready just
give me your hands
[Music]
open sesame
and every step you go down you get
closer
i never used
when i snap my finger you will open your
eyes
and you will tap dance your way around
the office
nah man
click right there sleep
i did it wake up
it doesn't say anything there's no like
i'm just kidding what they do
that was the most terrifying thing ever
i'm not doing it again it's done it's
over i'm gonna bring in an expert right
when the expert was about to enter the
room i actually got really nervous
i didn't know what i was getting into
but i was ready to learn how's it going
good how are you good good to meet you
you are the hypnotist
i am you hypnotize people i do before i
actually
have you be a part of this video i need
to make sure you're legit so would you
be able to perform hypnosis on me to
prove that you can do it absolutely do
you want to be hypnotized
i do i really want to get hypnotized
it's about you allowing yourself to
relax
your conscious mind we're able to go
through the critical factor
and put suggestions in there to help you
with stress i actually had chronic
headaches for two years
i went to doctors i took all kinds of
medication nothing helped and then i
went to a therapist who does hypnosis
and all she did was just talk to me as i
was relaxed my headaches were cured and
i'm not scared of flying anymore
i generally have people stop smoking in
one session that's it you're done he
told me to close my eyes and just relax
and listen to his voice and then he
started doing some crazy stuff
so just take a nice deep breath
deeper relaxed just letting go five
deeper
four deeper relaxed three really feeling
good two
fully relaxed and when i count from one
to three
it'll be as if you're a male stripper
one
two three
how are we doing eric how do you feel
[Music]
i'm good you want to see some stuff
dance with your baby
tonight
[Music]
i don't know how they do it in magic
mike but what guys this is my first time
watching this footage i'm mind blown i'm
uncomfortable so i just want to tell you
exactly what was going through my mind
because it looks so crazy so when he was
talking to me i just felt super relaxed
and like i was meditating and just
listening to his voice but as soon as he
said you're going to be like a male
stripper or whatever in my head i
thought you know
you i'm not gonna do that and then he
snapped his fingers i opened up and i
stopped caring and my body just started
moving i didn't know what i was doing i
was just
okay with it it felt really good that's
what's weird about it i felt really
relaxed
and like free but i just want to clarify
a lot of people think that hypnosis is
like oh you're this puppet and you're
unconscious and someone has control over
you it's not
you know what's going on the whole time
and it's crazy sorry i just have to get
that out there let's get back to the
video
a lot of my friends said hypnosis was
fake so we're gonna go around the office
right now and just hypnotize a bunch of
my friends
how you feeling today honestly i'm a
little stressed how would you like to
be more calm and be more relaxed i've
been trying to like meditate
and relax at work all my three years
here so if you can actually give me
something that works
i will be shocked there is something
about this
man in his eyes there's something inside
that it's already very hypnotizing the
hypnotist spent the next 10 minutes
trying to relax each person
and once they were ready he put him in a
trance
[Music]
it looked like he was knocking these
people out unconscious but they were
just super relaxed
sarah was so relaxed that she just fell
to the floor
[Music]
it didn't work on everyone though one
dude just go ahead and just relax you
have to be open to getting hypnotized
and just let things go
dave let things go a little too much his
eyes went white and if a person's eyes
are fluttering that means they're in a
hypnotic state he told each person to
imagine their happy place and to rub
their fingers together by doing so
they're creating an
anchor point and so every single time
they do this motion they'll be able to
go back to their happy place
it was really cool to see what a
positive effect the hypnosis had on each
person
oh my god i feel like i just came out of
an hour-long massage
i know except i was able to actually
like relax i'm excited to try this at
night because i have
like a lot of trouble sleeping bad
anxiety it was not scary
it was just very relaxed and it was like
finally
being able to reach this meditative
state you know we don't take enough time
for ourselves you know these days to
really think and connect i'm glad people
loved it so much and you guys get to see
that there's more to hypnosis than just
acting like a fool but obviously i still
made him put them back into a trance so
we can mess with them he made sarah
forget the number six
go ahead and count on your fingers from
one to ten one
two three four five
seven eight nine 10.
he convinced her every math problem he
equaled 382. how much is uh one plus one
182. how much is five plus zero
he made brenda forget her name my name's
brian what's your name
diana diana cool is that
is that her name diana
wait what's your name by the way i'm
sorry what was your name again
my name is brian what was your name
isn't that weird
he also made her forget english and told
her she can only speak martian
what is your favorite kind of food
and then what's the culture like that uh
making an ogan outside
i've been watching this guy all day and
i think i know what i need to do it's
all about just making the person feel
comfortable turning on their imagination
by having them think about a place
they'd like to be
and then once they're fully relaxed
their eyes are fluttering their head is
hanging loose you give them a suggestion
and snap your fingers or count to three
so i thought why not bring somebody in
who's had control over me my entire
life flip things around i'm gonna
hypnotize my mom so as soon as i snap my
fingers and say sleep
i want you to try to go back to that
state of relaxation drop your body relax
one two three sleep
so once i say three you will open your
eyes and only be able to speak and
communicate in russian three
how's it going i don't mind now no one
understands you here stop do you speak
english
you're auditioning for american idol you
will sing your original song
[Music]
nope no
i and
sleep i think i did it hypnosis is very
fun helps people relax rest go to sleep
if you can't sleep at night if you have
too many thoughts and
it's also fun if you can kind of give
people suggestions and they go along
with it
all right so normally when i finish
these types of videos i freak out and
i'm like oh my god i did it i mastered
it i did it but the reason i wasn't
freaking out in this video was because i
couldn't figure out if my mom was faking
it or not because if she wasn't that
means that i
actually hypnotized her it just doesn't
seem possible you guys are not excited
so i feel like you know she's lying
is she lying i've been trying to figure
it out this whole time mom are you
serious
i'm serious well it's up to the audience
to decide if i really hypnotize my mom
or not i don't know so i'm not faking it
my mom might be taking this whole thing
just give the audience a little juice if
you're lying admit it right now
[Music]